ننتقل الان الى الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا اذا قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها دمرت مستودع صواريخها ومدفعيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه بالقرب من بالجوري في منطقه
زباروتيا كما حذرت القوات المواليه لروسيا
بان اوكرانيا تستعد الاقتحام محطه سبارود
جل النوويه بمئات من نخبه مقاتلها بينما
نفت الرئاسه الروسيه المعلومات عن انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من المحطه من جانبها اكد
الجيش الاوكراني وانا قواته دمرتيا جسرا
للسكك الحديديه استخدمته القوات الروسيه
لمد الوحدات المقاتله بالمانيا والعتاد
في هذه الاثناء حذر مسؤولون اوكرانيون من
غارات الروسيه قد تشنوا في انحاء البلاد
اليوم الثلاثاء وقال رئيس الاداره
العسكريه والاقليميه في مقاطعه ميكولايب
البلاد ان الطائرات الروسيه نفذت خلال
ساعات الاخيره طلعات جويه ما وصفها فوق ما
وصفها بالاراضي الاوكرانيه المحتله